y en su doctorado y ya había tenido una
cercanía y había tenido y tenido cursos
con el nobel del grafito y me dice tú
haces nanopartículas yo a grafeno
hagamos una funcionalización del grafeno
qué significaba esto colocarle al
grafeno unas nanopartículas que yo
fabricaba
se le digo vaca empezó así nuestra vista
y con ella logramos conseguir varios
proyectos que nos financiaron para
desarrollar el grafeno en el perú y en
brasil también nos dieron subvenciones
para que los estudiantes pudieran viajar
no me olvido de darle las gracias al
nuevo batería consiste porque si no lo
digo después me dicen no has colocado
las gracias por haberte dado a los
fondos entonces gracias por ello
la cuestión es que desde el 2013 pudimos
con mi colaboradora de brasil trabajar
con el tránsfer y mencionó grafeno
grafeno y no digo exactamente qué cosa
es el grafeno el grafeno viene a ser el
material hasta ahora llamado por los
científicos como el material del futuro
pero este material está conformado por
átomos de carbono que si nosotros
tuviéramos un microscopio electrónico
podríamos ver un gran panal de abejas y
en los vértices de estos panal de abejas
vendrían a ser los átomos
o sea está en la mitad de carbono es una
lámina atómica
y esta es la cta atómica tiene
propiedades increíbles
uno que es más resistente que el acero
se considera cien doscientas veces más
resistente que el acero
su dureza es comparable con la del
diamante
y a pesar de que es resistente y de que
es duro es sumamente flexible entonces
esta flexibilidad dureza su alta
conductividad tanto del calor como de
electricidad lo convierte en material
lúdico
y por ello estamos muchos científicos
enfocados en trabajar con él y como les
narraba la historia con mi colega
brasileña o peruano brasileña fuimos a
su laboratorio y aprendimos a hacer el
grafeno como ellos lo habían venido a
hacer de los 9 o del 9 y era básicamente
por el método de exfoliación mecánica en
qué consiste este método de exfoliación
mecánica pues simplemente agarrar un
grafito y este grafito con una sintes
cost sacar caja o cama atómica y dónde
está el grafito
en un lápiz cualquiera que tienen
ustedes tenemos grafito pues con ese
grafito que son varias capas de grafeno
en brasil lo sacamos con unas interés
cosas dicho sea de paso tenía que tener
cuidado con la cinta con el sustrato que
utilizamos para colocar este grafeno
pero que lo teníamos en tamaños
pequeñitos muy pequeñitos a nivel de
micras
entonces yo podría mirar la partícula en
esa mitra de trasfondo que trabajábamos
en brasil y meses estudiantes acá en
llamas me decían profesora pero tratemos
de hacer el grafeno con otros métodos
hagamos en el centro del perú ok
probemos entonces como les comentaba que
nos dieron fondos comenzamos a comprar
activos y con mi grupo de estudiantes
uno de ellos sobre todo muy entusiasta o
químico
comenzamos a desarrollar es justamente
un método de síntesis química y lo
logramos
logramos primero obtener el óxido de
grafeno que viene a ser el precursor del
grafeno y con una reacción química o un
tratamiento físico lo grabamos el
grafeno cuando logramos este grafeno han
hecho aquí made in perú salta
según piel mis estudiantes decían
profesora la hicimos por fin tenemos el
grafeno y nos dimos a este lujo de
conseguir grafito netamente peruano pero
que estaba purificado y logramos grafeno
entonces al empezar a ser de la fe no
aunque reactivos químicos nos empezó a
abrir una gran puerta para aplicarlo en
diferentes años mi colega de brasil
también se interesó muchísimo e
intercambiamos las formas de trabajar
con metraje no porque ya lo hacía con
como les decía con la filiación mecánica
y nosotros lo trabajábamos con métodos
químicos todo iba bien hasta que el 2015
más o menos el 2014 la ciudad prohibió
el uso de reactivos sobre todo los
creativos que se utilizan para hacer
droga
y la canción o sea no podríamos producir
más grafeno como el método que habíamos
desarrollado porque los reactivos eran
controlados entonces acá el agua y se
forma una dependencia en la cual nos
decían que si no se encontraba un ácido
o reactivo controlado en el laboratorio
directo a la cárcel con esa motivación y
ese incentivo comenzamos a buscar otros
métodos de trabajo ya no veíamos el
método de exfoliación mecánica porque ya
lo teníamos trabajado y empezamos a leer
los métodos de ultrasonido de cavitación
para tratar de hacer el traje inclusive
comenzamos a hacer molienda con grafito
para obtener el grafeno y estamos en eso
trabajando en busca de nuevos métodos
para obtener el grafeno pero en el
camino hemos logrado trabajar y hacer
algunos dispositivos y bueno la charla
no solamente es hablar del grafeno sino
también de las aplicaciones como les
decía la atracción
este material es que es único
imagínense ustedes un avión en el cual
ustedes necesitan cables de cobre los
cuales son los que conducen los
circuitos y estos cables de cobre están
si en vez de utilizar estos cables de
cobre utilizamos para freno el grafeno
pues es mucho más ligero pesa muchísimo
menos y aligeraría de manera en manera
considerable el peso de este avión
como es resistente este grafeno puede
recubrir ciertos
superficies y hacerlas más resistentes
entonces también se piensa que en el
futuro aunque ya haya algunos prototipos
en los cuales los autos son cubiertos
con grafeno para hacerlos más
resistentes y a la vez bajar el peso que
considera que se daría si es que
utilizáramos un material fuerte y de
mayor resistencia
no solamente eso actualmente en el mundo
y hay empresas que se dedican a producir
de la gente
en españa es uno de los primeros
productores de grafeno hay cuatro
empresas grandes que comercializan
grafeno
también en el asia corea-japón sobre
todo corea fabrica grafeno pero la
limitante que se tiene hasta el momento
para despegar con las aplicaciones
vender afe no es que no sea escalado de
la producción de grafeno hasta el
momento es a nivel mundial o sea no
llegamos ni siquiera a 10 kilos de
producción al año en todo el mundo
detrás en o no se ha escalado porque
como les comentaba la técnica que usaba
mi colega en brasil fabrica pequeñas
láminas de grafeno si uno quiere hacer
un grafito perfecto un panal perfecto de
abejas con sus carbonos en los vértices
tiene que utilizar técnicas muy
especializadas
que necesitan una gran inversión para
poder realizarlas y encima la cantidad
de granjeros que produce se es muy
pequeña los métodos químicos que hemos
aplicado aquí y que nos ayudan a
centrarse no
se puede trabajar mayor cantidad de
grafeno pero el gra siendo que se
obtiene no es tan perfecto o sea y cada
una de las formas de trabajar tiene
ventajas y desventajas por lo que hasta
ahora no se despliega la aplicación y
vale
porque en el momento que se haga
prácticamente todo va a cambiar ya
actualmente no se se habrán visto en las
redes o en el internet al teléfonos que
son flexibles
porque estos teléfonos están hechos de
grafeno en este momento samsung lidera
una patente con la cual ha desarrollado
la lámina de grafeno más grande y con
esa lámina puede hacer teléfonos que son
flexibles y transparentes
y no lo están o sea no solamente en
aplicaciones electrónicas están se está
usando el grafeno también se está viendo
el grafeno para utilizarlo en la
medicina
ya se están utilizando algunos sensores
por los cuales se puede medir la
cantidad de insulina en sangre
y sensores de grafeno están colocando
placas de grafito para monitorear los
dedos pasa internamente y como es un
buen conductor y hecho a base de carbón
o el frío compatible
entonces las futuras aplicaciones de
grafeno en términos médicos y biológicos
son sumamente amplios
en la parte de agricultura también se
está pensando en trabajar con
fertilizantes que puedan controlar la
alimentación de la planta y poder
controlar los nutrientes que se les
pueda dar justamente con este grafeno y
algunos otros materiales que permitan
ese control
no quedarnos con eso
últimamente muy atento últimamente fue
el año pasado que estudiantes smith
desarrollaron una membrana para
y sale el agua que utiliza la gracia
y tengo actualmente un proyecto con el
cual también estamos pensando filtrar y
purificar el agua soportando trasero
sobre arena
hasta el momento los resultados van
encaminados esperamos tener un producto
del próximo año que nos ayude justamente
a este problema del agua
bueno no solamente en el agua para
descontaminar metales pesados o para
desalinizar la también podemos ver
que en la parte de militar ya han
desarrollado también dispositivos como
siempre los militares dispositivos como
de hacernos proteger visto mucho
potencial pero acá hacerte colombia ahí
es trabajos
hay una patente inclusive de chalecos
antibalas
para protegerlos con grafito y el
grafeno al ser más ligero pesa menos y
en la parte de seguridad recubre los
cascos con grafeno para proteger
los obreros en cualquier trabajo
industrial o sea la revolución del
grafeno está tocando nuestra cuerda
pienso que en pocos años en nuestro país
si toman conciencia de los empresarios
vamos a desarrollar muchos productos con
grafeno y no vamos a estar digamos tan a
la zaga preparado como
bueno les agradezco su atención gracias
[Aplausos]